When a person fails to keep up
with their rent on a storage unit,
the contents of that locker go up for auction.
People can then bid on those items based on a mere
glimpse of what's visible from the outside, only
learning what treasures lie within after they've
forked over the cash they bid during the auction.
It's a high-risk-high-reward scenario, and that's
exactly why millions of people have tuned in to
watch A&E's hit series Storage Wars for years.
The main cast of Storage Wars regularly
battle it out for hidden treasures,
taking what most people would
consider junk, renovating it,
and selling for a profit. Few people excel
at this as well as Mary Padian, who was
introduced to viewers in Storage Wars: Texas
before moving to the main series in season 5.
Known as "The Junkster," Padian
quickly became a fan-favorite for
her peppy attitude and willingness to go
the extra mile to find amazing trinkets.
"Where's Ricky?"
"Who?"
"Ricky."
"I don't even know what you're talking about."
"I already psyched you out.
You forgot your partner."
She'd then used her winnings from the show to sell
all kinds of idiosyncratic objects in her store,
Mary's Finds. But before she was a businesswoman,
Padian was just an average college student
... provided the normal college experience
involves getting followed around by
Secret Service everywhere you go.
Let's rewind the clock to the late '90s and
early 2000s. That's when Padian attended the
University of Texas at Austin, eventually
obtaining a photojournalism degree in 2003.
The University of Texas at Austin also
happens to be the college that a certain
U.S. president's daughter attended — and at the
same time that Padian was there. Jenna Bush,
the daughter of President George W. Bush,
earned her bachelor's degree in English in 2004,
a year after Padian graduated. Given that
a Bush was on the UT Austin campus during
the height of George W. Bush's presidency,
it makes sense that there might be Secret
Service people walking around. But why was
Mary Padian someone they also followed?
During a podcast interview with
The Mystery Men back in 2016,
Padian revealed that she not only knew Jenna
Bush, but was also her roommate for a time.
When the podcast hosts questioned whether she
saw a lot of Secret Service detail during her
time as Bush's roomie, Padian confirmed that
there were a lot of agents around to keep an
eye on Bush. As Bush's roommate, Padian
naturally ended up with Secret Service
protection as well — but only when she
was with Bush, not when she was alone.
She went on to say of the experience,
"It was crazy, but it was her
life. She didn't choose it,
you know? She was indifferent to it.
[...] It was fine, but it wasn't."
Padian later shared that wherever Bush
decided to go, the agents would follow.
The hosts then asked what it was like to go to
a college bar requiring that kind of protection.
Padian revealed that she would often forget
the Secret Service agents were even around,
and only when looking back on the experience
does she remember how unusual it was.
"Looking back on it, I'm like, 'Oh
my God,' you know? But at the time,
no, [I didn't notice]. I mean, they're Secret
Service — they're trained professionals.
They know what to do. It was just her dad was
the president. I felt bad for her at times."
Following graduation, Padian landed a job with
Architectural Digest, and was mentored directly
by editor-in-chief Paige Rense. Years later,
she'd return to Texas to start Mary's Finds.
And it seems that Padian may have kept in touch
with Bush over the years — or at least until
fall 2013, as evidenced by a tweet Padian
sent to Bush. On October 31 of that year,
Bush tweeted a photo of her mother, Laura Bush,
holding her daughter Margaret Laura "Mila" Hager,
who was dressed as an astronaut for Halloween.
Padian responded to the sweet picture,
"She is so cute, Jenna!! I cant even take it."
You know how the saying goes: College roommates
who have Secret Service protection together
stay together ... or something like that.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite reality stars are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.